[Music]
welcome to best life 30 your 30 day
journey to creating the best life
possible for yourself
you can just watch this video or if you
want to sign up for the entire series
for free and get the companion
bonus worksheets that go with this video
check the link in the description below
alright so today is day 21
and we're gonna learn how you can make
money from your ideas
[Music]
one of the things i saw a lot in my
comments because i read them all
was well i have no money i'm like i
lived my whole life with no money but i
figured it out
i would just buy [ __ ] i would buy garage
sale [ __ ]
and it just got me going going i love it
it's like a hobby of mine to go garage
sale
doing that with clothes i did i used to
do that with clothes dude you met guys
especially like a stylish kid like you
like if you have flavor if you're
listening right now and you don't have
money
but you're cool or you got flavor you
got swag
you got style if you just spend your
life in goodwill
and in thrift stores yeah and buy [ __ ]
that you think is fresh
and then wear it and take a selfie and
put it on ebay for
three times the price or like i see
every day the amount of people that buy
three dollar t-shirts and sell them for
35 bucks
on ebay and etsy and facebook
marketplace is enormous
there's no excuse in america to say you
have no money
even if you're in the deepest poorest
places because if you can
literally get a dollar you can buy your
first t-shirt at goodwill
and get it up for 15 bucks on facebook
because you know what's funny
what's funny is everybody's got a
smartphone
like you go into the poorest places in
america and everybody's got a smartphone
which means you have the internet i mean
listen the homeless
you've got people all over on home
homeless smartphones i get emails
every day i'm homeless i watch you on
youtube
you know so i don't know i really and
listen of course there's one percent
that don't and i
that's what's always fascinating to me
the one percent that populates like what
about my aunt i'm like cool i get it
but i'm trying to address 99.9 of people
and the garage sale thing's been huge by
the way
huge i have tens of thousands of tweets
emails dms messages from people over the
last hundred days
who are completely inspired by the show
and are making significant money
and significant comes in all forms do
you know what it's like
to make an extra 200 bucks a month when
you're not doing well financially
huge huge like it matters
it's also fun for 50 percent of people
like that's the i watch the videos and
i'm watching you like go and you're
getting you're you're picking up these
stuffed animals
do you know what this is gonna sell for
40 bucks 50 bucks
and seven bucks i get pumped like buying
something for a quarter
selling it for 11 on ebay with the fees
with all the [ __ ] that everybody
makes fun of me in the comments for what
about the gas
all that like i'm still like i made six
bucks i bought it for a quarter i sold
it for 11.
net six bucks or i could be on my couch
right now watching
netflix like if you complain and you're
unhappy
i will spend my career suffocating the
living [ __ ] out of you
the thing about garage sale that really
turns me on is the thrill of the hunt
because it's
the place where you can really score a
huge box of toys for three bucks worth
three hundred how many yeah i'm gonna
carry on you
uh you're like 400 i don't need that
much
15 bucks 30 bucks like i don't know
usually
usually truly you only need about 100
bucks this could be decent
it looks a little too new but we're
about to
strike they're striking to be done here
how much are the stuffed animals 50
cents
spongebob baby
all right stuffed animals continue to be
my score 50 cents a pop dumbo disney
store
snuffle up i guess spang olaf what and
this one's gonna be a beast
the fao schwartz fao schwartz giraffe
so we just looked it up the uh the
jeffrey uh
giraffe toys r us fao shorts combo 30
bucks
i'd love to pay 50 cents and i'm not to
say after ebay fees just like a quick 20
bucks
just a lot of people not making 20 bucks
an hour
not just one of the things wait till i
look up the snuffle over this
thank you so much this is pretty
exciting to me vintage lego thing never
opened
uh about 2003 jesus i'm getting old but
still 15 years old i'm excited to
open this up this was a huge score
already looked it up
paid three they wanted five paid three
uh for these spider-man skates in
package never opened as well
or opened um pretty excited about it
oh don't worry
[Music]
that's so awesome i heard all right
let's go
yeah she goes at least go around the
corner don't kill me
so good so good lego four zero nine
eight
25 bucks give it to me
all right pay two bucks for this all
right cool
so some ac snow globes in there
and they are better than i think
you didn't go back i play yep
would you do ten if i bought three yeah
okay you have a bag
i do have a bag awesome this is freaking
exciting
we just bought three snow globes for 10
bucks
and i'm fired up i'm fired up my guy
i'm fired up all right how do you feel
feeling really good now it's starting to
get hot
getting some stuff now well over the 200
range maybe a little bit more even feel
much better
a whole lot when you need it i like
it's probably warm we'll see
what it says too would you take a dollar
fist sure thanks
all right picked up this scary bear for
a dollar
called for real from tiger 2004 let's
see what it's worth
20 bucks all day all day 20 bucks
who me because i get more excited about
this than like
i get an angle
just picked up two jerseys for two bucks
a piece kevin durant
seattle supersonic jersey pretty rare
two bucks
garnett really nice one actually
stitched celtics
two bucks each we'll see 64 bucks for
the
durant i mean all right
you know pay two bucks you saw my
there's a little bit of like shitty
stains on it i can clean that off
it's just crazy if i was really doing
this
like on just saturday just working
saturday night
so ugh i mean
i genuinely think goodwill
ebay buying bulk on ebay selling in ams
like i just think this is the 100
000 a year thing for so many people
making
30 to 60 000 a year i feel phenomenal
this is the big final score it's about
100 bucks minimum and now i know about
cherish teddies
now i'm a cherished teddy's player and
every time you become more of a player
of a new thing
look this is very simple spent 40 50
20 40 bucks 50 bucks easily now into the
five or six hundred dollar range of
resale
i just wish so many of you would do this
it's four or five six hundred bucks
every weekend it's now 11 47
so we're four hours in a little gas
money
i get it but like net net two three four
hundred bucks
every weekend and if you don't want to
be like tedious because now you gotta
post in all this
cool just throw up this huge collection
of cherished teddy's 80 bucks boom quick
little you know 60 bucks here
adds up when you got groceries when you
got bills when you got college
loans when you got rent people sitting
around dwelling
85 90 this country working you know
minimum wages low incomes
it just matters teaching people how to
fish flip life it's real
when you were again in the early days
yeah at one point you only had
10 shirts how did you utilize the power
of broke
to get the word out so you know when
when you you know jay abraham
who you know is really my mentor he
loves to say opm is other people's uh
manufacturing manpower marketing mentors
and you can make money over other
people's mistakes
and i took inventory of myself and i
knew i wanted to get into this area of
business but
my inventory was that my liabilities
were i knew nothing about manufacturing
but my assets were that everybody was
shooting these little videos around the
neighborhood they weren't like these big
diddy videos at a million dollars i mean
this guy
this was like you know guy with a little
camcorder or something
and i knew that these people wanted uh
they needed clothing
and when they would have the nike send
stuff to them
nike didn't appreciate them so i would
go to the set and see an llc
and i would i would still say 18 hours i
get kicked off with
three or four of those sets but the one
time that somebody allowed me to put a
shirt on them
i put a shirt on them and then i would
take it back and i would keep putting on
different wrappers and different
wrappers and different i'm taking it
back and
and i made sure that i didn't dry clean
these things so they made sure they gave
them back because they stinked right
so i knew they gave some stinky
yeah i gave them something yeah sure you
got damn right now
um i love it um but these videos started
to rotate and you know
corporate america didn't understand the
power of videos at that time
and i started become known as a huge
clothing company meanwhile
i'm still a waiter and baldwin long
island and i have these ten little
stinky t-shirts in my basement but
i was doing something i loved i would
have went on those video sets for free
i was talking to a video chick i was
eating the free food over there i was
watching
old dirty bastard be old dirty bastard
so you know
i would have paid to be on those sets
yeah i'll do something i love when
ello cool j and some famous artists
started to wear your clothes you were
still full-time at red lobster i was
full-time you know
because we've we've seen too many movies
where it says
you know go balls to the wall burn every
bridge oh by the way other people's
money it's wreckable
that's [ __ ] right um the bottom line
is don't quit your day job
right because you know here's what was
happening as a waiter or lobster maybe i
made 30 or 40 000
right but if i did that which i did for
five years and i got i would i would
work my 60 hours of red lobster then i
put in another maybe
15 or 20 hours working on fubu but if i
had to pay myself for those five years
that would have been
200 000 now i'm 200 000 i would i had
two hundred thousand dollars i had
medical i was eating as many shrimp as i
would like i was using my network at red
lobsters to get things out of the
you know out i was learning from the net
uh the red lobster network of their
corporation their books
on how they do business and i was able
to do
my business longer yeah and and go
through the pitfalls of it
and the business started to call me i
started to now work
20 on the business 80 percent of red
lobster then all of a sudden
80 on the business and 20 there
but you know all these people who hear
all those stories about uh you know take
out large loans and just go for it
it's a lie they should never do that so
many people they want these instant
results and it's like
it's not the way to do it they listen
every every overnight success has taken
15 years and that's just the way it goes
and they've just watched too many people
you know you know who tells them all
this
the people that are trying to take their
money yes you know
the people the people that are trying to
take your money work twice as hard so
they go
take this magic pill you're gonna lose
weight you're gonna i'm gonna educate
you and what just come to my seminar and
buy a hundred thousand dollar pack
those are the people that are full of
crap and and other people out there who
don't wanna put in the work
unfortunately nobody's going to help you
i went to dallas
after college because a bunch of my
buddies were down there
and i got a job working as a bartender
at night and was looking for a job
during the day and got a job working for
a retail software company and this was
in the early days of pcs
and was doing okay there and then about
nine months in
i made um let me add i was living six
guys in a three bedroom apartment
and i was sleeping on the floor it was
the rattiest nastiest
hole you've ever seen in your life i
mean and i literally didn't have a
closet
didn't have a drawer all my was in a
pile on the floor
i had my one towel that i stole from
motel 6 that had a hole in it
that was mine um and so
i was trying to grind it out and learn
tech which i really
realized that i loved and i made the one
day i called up my boss a guy named
michael humecki
h-u-m-e-c-k-i and i said michael i've
got this deal i'm going to close now
it's 1500
commission to me which meant i can move
out of the show and and so
i said one of my responsibilities was to
open up the retail store
you know make sure the door was open the
floors were clean and all that kind of
stuff i said look
i've got this big deal i want to close
it and he said no you need to be at the
store i'm like
i got someone to watch goes no you need
to be at the store so i made the
executive decision that
if i went and picked up a fifteen
thousand dollar check for this company
um your business software he would see
the light and all would be good
and i'd have my 1500 commission fired my
ass
um seriously michael humecki and
i'm not going to assuming you've spoken
one time one time literally after
broadcast.com went public
he sent me a letter asking if i would
invest in his company
you should bring him on shark tank
anyway so that was the only time i
talked to michael humecki
and so and so he fired me
and so there i was still in this show
with my one motel six towel
um and no bedrooms and so it was then
that we started micro solutions and i
had no money
and so i went to this company called
architectural lighting and i said look i
got nothing
but i know you were trying you want this
time in billing software
if you front me the 500 i'm going to
start this company and i promise you
that i'll make it work and if i can't
make it work i'll walk your dog
i'll wash you know your car i'll do
whatever to make it up to you
just trust me and give me the shot they
did i took that 500 dollars bought the
spent 250 on the software got that to
work really fast
and then asked for referrals and built
this company that
then went on to become one of the first
companies that did local area network
this was the early 80s
and then went wide area networks and as
you said we sold it to compuserve
and along the way i kept on reinvesting
and
one day i went to the atm and i had all
zeros
you know which which was not fun but
like you said we ended up building it we
had
36 million dollar revenue run rate and
sold it to compuserve which is part of h
r block and you know all was in
alignment again and
it wasn't like i started it thinking
okay if i fail i don't care
it was purely out of necessity i didn't
know what else to do there's a design
conference coming to san francisco
and there's not a single place to stay
in the city and
i'm looking around the apartment seeing
all the space in our living room
thinking wait there's all this extra
space what if
we took an airbed out of the closet we
blew it up on the floor and
we hosted guests who needed a place to
stay i called brian said brian
we're gonna throw air beds on the floor
we're gonna host guests this weekend
we wants just in time for south by
southwest and we had about 10 people
list their place in austin
and a total of two reservations
one of which was brian
so we were not met with success it did
not take off like a rocket ship
in fact i would call it a miserable
failure at that
point well we actually had 20
introductions to investors throughout
silicon valley
10 of those people replied to our email
five of them met us for coffee
zero invested in airbnb
and talk about a tough time you've got
some of the smartest people in the world
you know they've picked some of the
the most well-known companies that we
all love and use today from google's
paypal youtubes
and here they are telling us that our
idea is crazy
that it's not going to scale that people
aren't going to stay in people's homes
around the world
kind of the world thought we were crazy
it was late one night in the kitchen
brian and i
are trying to keep our spirits up and
we're brainstorming crazy ideas like
what if we provided breakfast to go
along with the air beds of air bed and
breakfast
it's the middle and the height of the
political conventions and and uh
campaigns
so we thought well let's make him
politically themed we'll call one obama
owes the breakfast of change
we'll call the other cat mccains
maverick and every bite one thing led to
the other
we ended up making cereal boxes and
selling them
online for forty dollars a box
we ended up making twenty thousand
dollars on breakfast cereal
so little known fact the obama's not
only got us to zero
like that's something to be proud of we
got up to zero but
we then got introduced to paul graham
phone rings it's paul graham he's
calling
to tell us that we've been accepted the
y combinator
and so what we later found out is that
the reason that paul led us in wasn't
because he thought our idea was amazing
he actually thought it was kind of weird
he let us in because he saw that with
the breakfast cereal
we could figure out how to do anything
and that's how we got into y combinator
it's our very first office hours with
paul graham
he's looking at brian 89 and he goes so
where's your market
and we kind of look at each other and
we're like thinking to ourselves we
don't really have a market no one's
using our service
but there are some people in new york
who are renting out their homes
and paul goes so your customers are in
new york city and you're here in
mountain view
go to new york city
we pull up the 20 hosts and search
results and we realize something
that the photography the images of their
listings
are actually not very good so we kind of
have this realization you know
we can solve that problem we know how to
take a good photo but it's not scalable
that's the thing is that up until this
point
we had tried to solve problems in a
scalable way which i think
i would call like some of the mythology
of silicon valley is that
you have to solve problems in a scalable
way that one line of code
has to meet the needs of hundreds tens
tens of thousands or hundreds thousands
or maybe millions of people so paul
graham comes along
and basically gives us this message
which was the single greatest piece of
advice we ever got
go meet your people do things that don't
scale
it'll teach you you'll learn from it so
we fly to new york that weekend
we rent a camera with a wide-angle lens
and we go from door to door
throughout manhattan and brooklyn so
here we are
in the environment of our customers
now watching them use our product in
real time and we're
seeing a lot of things that we didn't
know were problems
we got so close that we got to step into
their shoes for a moment
and see the world through their eyes and
really
see the pain points that they were
feeling and that to me is like
that's the basics of innovation you take
an enlightened empathetic point of view
for your customers you combine it with
your own
unique point of view the world to create
something new
you know what happened because of this
they started using the word
love in the same sentence as airbnb they
started telling their neighbors their
friends their family members their
co-workers
and so two things started to happen
simultaneously the amount of choice
started to go up and the quality of that
choice went up
as well and when a new host came to the
site they said oh well i guess i need to
have really nice photos to be in the
part of this marketplace
and we started to see the number of
reservations go up for any entrepreneur
out there
like you can't take no for an answer you
know we had really smart credible people
telling us
no and had we listened to them there
might not be airbnb today
when i first met warren back in 1959
i recognized immediately that he was a
very intelligent
person for the last four or five years
the stock market has been booming along
and
presumably forecasting better business
which is really not materialized
so maybe the stock market is really
correcting a previous incorrect forecast
this time rather than making a new
correct one
he made a lot of money buying thinly
traded securities
that were incredibly cheap statistically
warren was at that time dealing with
small companies
and his investments often were to buy a
company
that you could figure was a discarded
cigar butt
but it had one more smoke in it and he
wanted to buy at the right time to be
able to benefit from the one smoke
the first partnership started with a
hundred and five thousand one hundred
dollars
i put up the hundred and the other
people put up the hundred and five
thousand
and then at the start of 1962 i moved to
kiwi plaza and by the time i moved to
keyword plaza we had seven million
dollars
invested and fair amount was profits
i was then renting a house i never owned
a house to that point
and then two years later i bought the
house i live in today
in 1958. people often think you know
well warren buffett was this famous rich
guy he was not famous and he wasn't rich
when we were growing up
what i saw first and foremost
day in and day out was consistency
every day we hear the garage door closed
in the house
and then like clockwork my dad would
come in the door
i'm home and we'd all eat dinner
together which i think surprises a lot
of people
you were a frustrated consumer i was
and you decided to try to solve a
problem what was the problem you were
trying to solve
well i couldn't figure out what to wear
under white pants
and i was a frustrated consumer the
undergarment options at the time were
not great right we had
underwear that left a panty line shape
uh girdles that were really thick and
uncomfortable
and then they invented the thong which
just put underwear exactly where we had
been trying to get it out of
so so i was like yeah i
know and um and listen at the time that
i
invented spanx and for the guys in the
audience or some of the ladies who don't
know what spanx is
it's just i invented an undergarment
that filled the gap between
traditional underwear and those heavy
duty shapers and i was interested in
giving
women a smooth canvas like i love
clothes i love
you know to be able to wear them but
just like a painter if you don't have
the right canvas it affects the whole
painting
and the options weren't great and they
could be seen they left lines they left
bulges
so that's what caused me to to invent
the first product which was the
first ever spanx the footless pantyhose
i actually
really manifested the idea so you know
it's like everyone's always like how did
you take an idea and then start a
business well it's how did you even come
up with the idea you know i was in
search of my idea
and at the time my life was not great i
was selling fax machines door-to-door
i was living with my mom i was like 25
years old
and i remember after a whole entire day
of being kicked out of office complexes
again
all day or sometimes my business card
ripped up in my face
i pulled off the side of the road one
day kathy and i was like i'm in the
wrong movie
like what just happened call the
director call the producer
this is not my life this is not my movie
and i went home that night i wrote down
my strengths or what i thought i was
good at
and the only thing in the good column
really was sales
and i thought okay well i know i'm good
at selling
what is it i like about selling and i
realized i like offering something to
someone that they need or didn't know
that they needed that can improve
their life or help them and so
in that moment i wrote down in my
journal i want to invent a product
that i can sell to millions of people
that will make them feel good
[Applause]
and
um and you know what and two years later
the idea came to me
and and i was ready for it you know
people women had been cutting the feet
out of their paneos for a long time
and i only did it one time but i had
already asked
the universe for my idea and i said when
it comes i will not squander it
and i will take it and run with it i
call neiman marcus around the corner of
my apartment in atlanta and i said hi
this is sarah i've got a product i want
to come show you and
the lady kind of laughed and said well
we have a buying office
and that's in dallas i thought oh okay
so i hung up and i called and called the
buyer and from my cold calling days i
knew i'm not going to leave a message
i'm going to keep calling until this
woman answers the phone
so the second she answered the phone i
took a very deep breath i was so scared
and i said
hi this is sarah blakely and i've
invented something that's going to
completely change the way all of your
customers wear clothes
and i'll fly to see you if you'll give
me five minutes and she just kind of
took a pause and she goes
well where do you live i said atlanta
she goes all right if you're willing to
fly here i'll give you 10
10 to 15 minutes so
i jumped on a plane and i went to the
neiman marcus headquarters
before i went i was you know my few
friends i had my lucky red backpack
they stopped me in my tracks i had my
closest friends they go sarah
please they were pleading with me please
don't bring that red backpack to the
neiman marcus headquarters
i mean this was my old backpack from
college it was just
dirty and you know they said do anything
you can't bring that red backpack i mean
if you need to go buy a prada bag return
it the next day i mean
whatever you need to do but don't bring
that red backpack
well i took a very deep breath i said
you know what this is my good luck charm
i gotta bring it so there off i went
with the ziploc bag in the pack
the backpack the color copy of the
packaging i
went to the neiman marcus headquarters
i'm sitting in front of this buyer
that was the most impeccably dressed
woman i'd ever seen in my life i mean
even her pen
matched her outfit i was just
and i was shaking i had my red backpack
on the floor and i
started going into my spiel and i was i
knew i wasn't really making a ton of
sense and so halfway through it i go
you know what you just have to come with
me in the bathroom
she's like excuse me i know i know it's
a little weird but just please come with
me to the bathroom i'm gonna do my own
before and after for you and then you'll
get it
so we walk down the hallway i mean in
total silence i'm like i can't believe
this
i go into the stall i have on the white
pants that cause me to invent it i come
out with the spanx on
i turn around i just shown her what it
looked like without the spanx on
and she took a step back and she goes i
get it
and then she goes it's brilliant
and then she said i'm going to give you
a shot i'm going to put you in seven
stores
but i cold called neiman sachs nordstrom
bloomingdale's
qvc i was out on the road and i think a
lot of entrepreneurs make the mistake
they think once you get the order you're
golden
and that couldn't be any farther from
the truth once you get the order that's
when the real
work starts i was absolutely determined
to ensure my
own success and i think that's what it
takes i didn't want my success to be
contingent on anyone else having to sell
this
so i hit the ground running and i went
from department store to department
store
and i would do morning rallies at the
store where i would gather people around
well the store manager said sarah you
know you can do it with the hosiery
associates well
i'd travel all the way to arizona and
there'd be three hosiery associates so i
quickly was like
i gotta get the whole store at this
morning rally so i would go into the
entrance before the store opened like a
neiman's or a sax or a bloomingdale's
and i would run around and introduce
myself to every employee setting up
their station i'd say hi i'm sarah
and i would try to convince them that it
would be worth their time to come see my
morning meeting and
i got everybody there i had taken the
oprah clip and the a little bit of local
press i'd
i'd received and put it on a video and
did that in my morning rally
and it was such an important thing that
i was doing i
inadvertently was building a sales force
that wasn't on my payroll and they
all across the country became my biggest
advocates for the product and started
selling it on
behalf of spanx and me everybody is
chasing the next thing the next
big thing the next shiny object when
what i do or what my students do is we
are
using the oldest ways to
make money see most people they are
looking at it yet they're stepping over
dollars to pick up dimes what i'm
talking about i'm talking about the good
old
telephone that's right the good old
phone
simple simple tool to make hundred
dollars
a day let me share my business model
with you my formula with you the very
same formula that i teach
all my students across the world the
high
ticket closing methodology here's how
it's going to work
imagine this there are companies out
there
nowadays it costs more
than ever to acquire customers so most
companies you notice there's advertising
it's costing more money than ever
because it's more competitive than ever
in the marketplace
so a lot of companies when they are
selling any kind of product
most products under 200 most of time
those are what i call the initial
product that
they're using those products in the
marketplace companies
entrepreneurs they're selling these
products hopefully to develop a
relationship with a customer is to
to break the wallet and just start the
relationship start the conversation
all the money is made after that 200
is spent when they realize hey you know
what once my customer
trusts our brand trust our company now
we can follow up with them and offer
them
other products and services that are at
the 2 000
five thousand ten thousand twenty
thousand twenty five thousand or
more that's where the money is made
here's the problem
those offers i refer them as high ticket
offers
five thousand ten thousand twenty five
thousand fifty thousand dollars
those sales they need to be closed on
their phone
very rarely people buy something at that
kind of price point looking at a video
or just
looking at a website they need to have
that one-on-one conversation
so what does that have to do with you
that's where you come in
imagine this let's say you are closing
for a company or you're closing for an
entrepreneur
let's say their offer is one thousand
dollars
and if you're a good closer you'll have
good closing skills
they are willing to pay you a hundred
dollars which is ten percent
of the sale ten percent commission
that's a hundred dollars
so i want you to think about it if
you're closing some of these
packages some of these products and
services one thousand bucks
you make a hundred dollars a sale that's
a hundred dollars a day all you need to
do
is what to make one single sale a day
that's it one single sale a day you get
your 100 bucks
what is your cost zero how many websites
you have to build
zero how many products did you buy zero
why because you're not selling your own
products you're not selling your own
offers
you're selling other people's offers
the company the influencer the
entrepreneur they are doing all the
marketing
they're doing all the lead generation
they're driving all the traffic they are
building a funnel they're creating
content they're writing a blog they're
creating videos
they're doing a press release they're
doing 90
of the work but yet they don't make the
money until someone like you and me
get on the phone and close those high
ticket sales
this is one of those very rare skills
that you can make your 100
a day with no expense and no
overhead now you may be thinking well
dan are you talking about being like an
annoying telemarketer
does that mean i have to cold call
people does that mean i have to do a lot
of prospecting oh my god like i can't do
that
i'm a shy person i'm not very talkative
it's not about
none of that [ __ ] i am talking about
talking
to people who have put up their hand i'm
talking about talking to prospects
you have gone through a series of steps
who have filled an application form and
then book a time to speak with you as a
high ticket closer
and then you close those sales that's
what i teach
zero cold calling has nothing to do with
building a website you don't have to do
anything online
and you don't have to cold call a single
person that's the power
of high ticket closing okay how do i
make money online
people always ask me how i make money
and i thought i'd just show you some
actual screenshots on my phone
on different products different
businesses i have here's today
one of my companies here seventeen
thousand three hundred and eighty four
dollars
uh today alone made seven hundred and
fifteen thousand in the last month
selling simple household items you know
i like books
that's how much i said i sold in books
and i got another company
you know i like glasses so we sell
glasses
sleep glasses i'll show you a little uh
screenshot of that one this is a shopify
this month it sold 17 000 today it's
done thirteen hundred bucks
there's an airplane coming in let me
give you a tour
and i'm gonna share with you four simple
steps that you can get started making
money online today now you're not gonna
start out
making seven hundred thousand dollars a
month like i'm doing it took me a while
to build up but
i'm telling you it's easier to start now
than it's ever been because when i got
started
you didn't have shopify amazon wasn't
easy to sell on you didn't have stripe
to collect credit card
uh number you know to collect the pr and
process payment and i'm going to show
you the four ways to get started
if you want within 24 hours making money
online
now like i said it's not a get rich
quick scheme but trust me there's simple
household items around your house
700 000 in the last month i've sold a
books and book related things you know
educational stuff
more this is just one business you could
sell i know people selling candles
making 100 grand
i know guys selling candles i think
you're going to make a couple million
bucks
everywhere you look so step number one
to making money online
find a household item that's interesting
to you that's step number one
find a simple household item that's
related to what you do on a day-to-day
basis like i said i sold
seven what did i sell on glasses 1300
today
and then this is just not showing amazon
amazon did about three or four thousand
days so about five thousand dollars a
day
and i also do stuff related to sleeping
well because everybody's got a bed and
gotta sleep
step number two decide if you wanna sell
using a website that you can build on
shopify click funnels or you can just
use
amazon you need to decide between those
three step number three
okay you gotta connect them and you
gotta get a way to collect
money so you can either use stripe
braintree
or if you sell on amazon they have built
in you can process through them i don't
recommend paypal as your only
source sometimes depends step number
four
once you got those is you need to white
label the products
so you don't want to have to create like
if you want to sell glasses or if you
want to sell
cosmetics or if you want to sell tables
you don't want to actually manufacture
them at least not to start
so there's a simple way that you can use
what's called white labeling or drop
shipping
to take products that people have and
put your own label and brand on it with
that said you can be up and going
with those four steps literally if you
start early enough today you can do it
today
be up and running now like i said you
gotta get sales
but that comes if you know how to do it
amazon literally has
i forget how many sales a day 80 million
sales a day
different items sold so if you can do
well in the amazon
ecosystem people will find you
especially if you know how to rank there
you know for some of you you might be
intimidated by trying to make
you know seven hundred and fifteen
thousand dollars a day
by the way we've been making money while
we were on this walk
or on this walk made a couple hundred
bucks in the last couple of minutes
that's the beauty by the way of selling
online i call it robotic
income like robot never gets tired it
just
does the work if you build a website
correctly using shopify or click funnels
or amazon they never get tired
those servers run as long as there's
electricity they're running
and one of the cool things if you want
to make a hundred grand a year a lot of
people think it's hard to make 100 grand
a year it is if you have a nine to five
job
because you're only working eight hours
a day but a robot never gets tired
robotic income there's no end it can run
24 hours a day
did you know to make a hundred thousand
dollars a year pull out a calculator and
do the math let me show you
a hundred thousand dollars a year okay
right there divided by 365 days because
a robot
a website can work non-stop is 273
a day right 100 divided by 365 days
then how many days are there i mean
hours in a day
you only got to make 11 and 41 cents an
hour 11
41 cents an hour you're making 100 000 a
year now i've got a special bonus clip
that i think you're gonna enjoy but
before that
it's time for the best live 30 questions
of the day
it's not enough to just watch a video
you have to do something about it so
pull out your worksheets and answer
these questions and if you don't have
the worksheets yet get them for free by
checking the link in the description
below
here we go question number one what is
your best idea
right now that you want to work on
number two what are the three
most important first steps to get
started and number three
how can you make those three steps
happen this week
and if you're doing the best life 30
challenge with me put a hashtag
bestlife30 in the comments below we want
to celebrate you
i think most people are confused about
money most people don't have a healthy
relationship with money
there are the people who think that
money is everything the money is the
only important thing in the world and
you need to chase it down and it's your
duty and responsibility and obligations
like it's number one
the person walking into my house and my
place of business that's my next suit
that's my next payment that's my next
whatever it's only focused on money
and there's other people who think money
is the root of all
evil and that money is a bad thing
money is a tool money helps you get a
lot of things done money helps you go
places money helps you accomplish your
mission
money needs to be in your top five it's
just not number one
money needs to be in your top five if
money does not become important at some
point to you if it's not in your top
five
priorities you'll never make money and
you'll always be by yourself
struggling trying to figure out how to
make something work but it's not number
one either
if you put money above all else you'll
end up doing a lot of work that you hate
and you never get good at it just
because you're chasing opportunities
this is a big reason why so many
entrepreneurs fail
you're just chasing the hottest thing
for this year
that you don't have a passion or
interest in and then you lose because
the people who love that destroy you
when i first started doing this helping
entrepreneurs i never thought i was
going to make money
my first speaking gig my first option to
help people was in canada in my hometown
of toronto
was at a ymca it was a free event they
had an entrepreneurship program they
asked me to come and speak to their
members
it was free i wasn't getting paid to do
it just wanted to help out i just sold
my business i wanted to give back
i was saying yes to everything i
actually didn't even know what i want to
do next
and so i show up and it's this big room
full of chairs
and only three people show up to that
first event
only three people and as soon as i
walked in the room and i saw three
people my heart sank
i felt like i'm never gonna be able to
make anything from this if only three
people
show up to a free event how am i ever
going to make money from it
[Music]
i didn't know but i gave my best to
those three people
i know that i helped those three people
and had an impact on their lives we then
went for coffee
afterwards and continued the
conversation i know that i helped them
and it filled my soul
i had to find a way to keep doing it i
knew i had to find a way to keep doing
it even if i never made money
and so i did i kept doing speaking gigs
i did my website
i did my youtube channel and slowly
slowly slowly slowly
it started to come in as i figured out
the second key
important piece which is figuring out
how to bring value to other people
when you find something that you love
doing and you combine it with how it
brings value to other people
that's when you start making money it
was something that you just love doing
but nobody else likes it there's zero
value to anybody else
you have a hobby you have a hobby if
you're only chasing stuff that people
like and need
but you don't like doing it you're never
going to get great at it
you might make a little bit of money but
you're never going to get great at it
you're never going to be
all time you're never going to build a
huge business
and so it's that combination of doing
work that you love doing
and mix it with where there's an
opportunity that people need it's a
problem that you are solving mix those
things together
you have a super successful business if
you want to join the best life 30
challenge click the link right here
below me or if you want more videos on
money making ideas check out the
playlist right there next to me
continue to believe and i'll see you
soon